Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Übrigens Linus, es besteht gerade keine Gefahr.
Okay, okay, ich informiere die Nachbarn.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertneunundfünfzig vom aufgepasst, elften September zweitausendundzwanzig.
Da sagt man, zwanzig zwanzig? Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung. Ist auch egal. Auf jeden Fall ist mal wieder nein eleven. Hätte es gedacht.
Ja. Das heißt, das ist jetzt neunzehn Jahre her, ne?
Ja, genau, neunzehn Jahre. Und das ist ganz interessant zu sehen, dass.
Irgendwie mittlerweile seinen seinen Nachrichtenwert ein wenig verloren hat. Also so die ersten paar Jahre,
immer so, oh, ein Jahr, nine eleven und vor zwei Jahren, nein, eleven und vor fünf Jahren eleven und bin mir nicht mehr so ganz so sicher, ich glaube dann nach zehn Jahren musste dann auch noch mal alles runtergebetet werden und die tausend Bilder gezeigt werden
Und ich dachte so, oh Gott, das geht jetzt ewig so weiter. Aber dann hat's irgendwann so ein bisschen seinen Schub verloren. Und dabei habe ich mich immer gefragt,
Okay, ab wann wird eigentlich Geschichte irrelevant? Also wann.
Die Ereignisse auch vielleicht für die aktuelle Generation und in gewisser Hinsicht dann eben auch,
Für den New Cycle, also es bedingt sich ja so ein bisschen. Ähm keine Rolle mehr oder so eine untergeordnete Rolle, dass das eben irgendwann ist, so wie so ein Fernsehbeitrag aus den Fünfzigern für uns.
Also ich würde ich wäre vorsichtig zu sagen es spielt keine Rolle mehr. Es gibt ja einen Unterschied zwischen ähm was weiß ich äh heute läuft nicht mehr den ganzen Tag hoch und runter, nein eleven. Und.
Wir haben aber,
uns zwanzig Jahre daran gewöhnt oder neunzehn Jahre daran gewöhnt, in einer Welt zu leben, die von diesen ähm Ängsten und Feindeslinien und Sorgen bestimmt ist. Ne, also die ganze Geschichte,
Terror, Islamismus und so weiter ist ja nach wie vor, es ist quasi in der Tiefe der Gesellschaft so dermaßen drin,
dass man sich, dass man schon gar nicht mehr in Frage stellt und vielleicht auch nicht jedes Jahr nochmal aufwärmen muss.
Das ist richtig, natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht hat natürlich alles so einen Langzeiteffekt und solche Großereignisse wirken eben auch länger nach. Was ich eher meinte, ist.
Ähm ab wann erinnern sich eben die Leute auch an diesen Moment so nicht mehr? Also ein vergleichbares Beispiel wäre äh Maueröffnung.
Was ja für viele Leute so eine einschneidende Geschichte war, ja? Und davor wird es halt Kriegsende gewesen sein und so. Und für mich war halt so Baujahr siebenundsechzig eben Kriegsende.
Wie gefühlt so im siebzehnten Jahrhundert, weil es halt nicht miterlebt habe und weil's.
Klar, man weiß das, das hat irgendwie stattgefunden, aber es wird halt im zunehmenden Maße schwieriger äh diesen Moment nachzufühlen, ne. Gab ja dann auch immer so dieses so jeder weiß.
Wo er war, als die Flugzeuge in das Hochhaus flogen. Ne, das war ja so ein,
Hatte da irgendwie seine Geschichte zu erzählen, die uns so so so ein definierender Moment, vor dem jeder weiß, wie man sich selber in dem Moment dazu verhalten hat oder wie man das erfahren hat oder was es mit einem gemacht hat und so. Und jetzt,
Wird es halt rausgeschoben durch die Zeit und durch durch andere Ereignisse überlagert. Ja und.
Keine konkrete Schlussfolgerung dadraus.
Ich finde das nur ganz interessant. Gerade immer an solchen Stichtagen zu sehen, wie eben so die Geschichte so langsam ins Off äh schiebt und andere Dinge eben auch relevant werden. Was ja auch gut kann man.
Andere Geschichte dann gibt.
Klar, weil's andere
andere Werte gibt, ne? Aber das äh dann auch eben ähm immer schwierig wird, Schlussfolgerungen zu ziehen. Und jetzt hatten wir gerade in der letzten Folge irgendwie diese ganzen Leute, die irgendwie einfach auch so mit diesem Begriff Nazi nicht mehr so richtig was
äh anzufangen, wissen offensichtlich und da äh ihre Lehren der Geschichte nicht gezogen haben, ja, weil sie halt an dieser Geschichte dann eben auch irgendwann einfach nicht mehr so richtig teilgenommen haben und auch nicht
bereit sind, da äh in die Vergangenheit zu schauen und äh sich,
ansatzweise zu vergegenwärtigen, welche welche Bedeutung das gehabt hat.
Hm. Ja.
Irgendwann werden die Leute sich nur noch an Blinkenlights erinnern, wenn äh elfter September gesagt wird, weil das war ja die eigentliche Nachricht des Tages.
Das war die eigene. Ja, wir haben auch noch eine Nachricht des Tages.
Völlig überraschend wusste der Chaos-Computer-Club dann,
sich jetzt mit der Nachricht auseinandersetzen, dass es wahrscheinlich nicht möglich sein wird, mit siebzehntausend Menschen
im Dezember in Leipzig einen Kongress abzuhalten. Es gab so wurde mir berichtet tatsächlich wohl noch einige Leute, die davon ausgingen, dass das passieren würde.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja auch wichtig, da so ein bisschen einfach äh sich positive Gedanken,
halten, ja? Und auch irgendwie Hoffnung nach vorne mit Hoffnung nach vorne zu blicken. Äh ja, als Präsenzveranstaltung wird der CCC-Kongress in diesem Jahr nicht stattfinden.
Stattdessen ähm wollen wir aber natürlich auch die Leute nicht,
in dieser kalten Jahreszeit mit diesen fest reservierten vier Tagen in ihrem Leben alleine lassen und deswegen gibt es die Remote KOS Experience,
geschrieben RC drei, ja? Also hier eine kleine eine kleine Spur, C drei ist da noch drin. Ähm es ist aber.
Eine komplett andere Plan, der dort entstehen soll, weil er eben nicht,
treffen der Menschen vor Ort beinhaltet. Ähm wir können ja sehr gut remote arbeiten, wir sind das ja gewöhnt, ja? Genau deshalb brauchen wir aber eigentlich auch dieses persönliche Treffen.
Jetzt haben wir uns halt lange Zeit überlegt, wie kann man denn, was ist denn das Beste, was man unter den gegebenen Bedingungen machen kann.
Und ähm wir haben da jetzt so in vielen, vielen,
mit vielen Leuten geredet und viele Ideen sind zusammengekommen, da kristallisierte sich so ein bisschen das Bild heraus, im Prinzip ein,
verteiltes Online-Event zu machen. Also ähm die Vision ist ein bisschen, dass es wahrscheinlich in vielen, mindestens aber mehreren Hacks in Deutschland kleinere Zusammenkünfte gibt.
Vielleicht da auch 'ne Bühne existiert, die dann eben als für ein,
Livestream eines Vortrags genutzt werden kann mit einem kleinen Publikum, damit die Speakerinnen nicht irgendwie ganz alleine zu Hause in ihre Webcams reden müssen, ähm aber vor allem mit,
dem mit dem ja zusammentreffen im kleineren Freundeskreis und dem Vernetzen äh im weltweiten Internet. Und.
Diese,
Vision, glaube ich, wenn man sich da langsam mal drauf vorbereitet und mit anfreundet, kann sich da äh jede von uns irgendwie ein, eine schöne Zeit zwischen den Jahren planen. Ja, ich normale Menschen,
machen das ja auch irgendwie, dass sie sich in dieser Zeit treffen, kochen, zu Hause hängen, ja? Ähm das das müssen wir dann, da müssen wir versuchen, uns ein bisschen dran anzupassen, dass andere Menschen zu der Zeit machen.
Und ich glaube, wie bei jeder Chaos-Veranstaltung ist am Ende das Entscheidende, was ihr daraus macht, also wer mit der Erwartungshaltung da drangeht,
setze mich zu Hause hin, mache am siebenundzwanzigsten zwölften,
den Stream an und dann wird's geil das wird diese Erwartung denke ich kann nicht erfüllt werden, ich glaube die wurde auch noch nie von von einem Kongress erfüllt, wenn man jetzt remote genommen hat, sondern die Frage ist wirklich, was kann man,
wie kann man sich die Situation selber schön gestalten im Freundeskreis? Oder auf den Malediven, wenn da noch ein Flug geht?
Und ähm wie kann man äh das, was dort geschieht, kreativ gestalten, denn der Kongress ist ja nicht geil, weil der CCC,
die Messe mietet und äh und da drin Vorträge äh stattfinden lässt, sondern der Kongress ist geil, weil da tausende Menschen mit tausenden Ideen hinkommen,
Workshops, große Workshops, Spiele, äh Kunst, Installationen und ein irgendwie ein Wunderwald macht, indem es Dinge zu entdecken gibt. Und das,
online abzubilden.
Ist natürlich eine Herausforderung und genau deswegen sind wir jetzt auch schon ja relativ früh mit dieser äh mit dem Aufruf rausgegangen,
an die Menschen zu sagen, ey überlegt euch doch schon mal,
wie ihr euch das gestalten wollt und was ihr beitragen könnt, was was wollt ihr machen? Was kann eure Crew online anbieten? Ähm um diese vier Tage irgendwie,
interessant ähm zu gestalten und irgendwie Onlinezusammenkünfte zu machen. Ich denke irgendwie an die weißt du, Kochworkshop ja.
Geht geht genauso remote, wenn man den Leuten eine Woche vorher sagt, welche Zutaten sie einkaufen müssen, ne? Oder vielleicht anderthalb Wochen vorher wird, damit man an diesen Hamsterkäufern da äh vorbeikommt, die Weihnachten immer meinen, das Ende der Welt naht.
Ähm und das Gleiche gilt natürlich für irgendwelche Workshops und so weiter. Da also,
man wird da jetzt einfach sehr viel Kreativität brauchen, um um sich diese Zeit ähm angenehm zu gestalten. Wir wollen dafür wie immer den den fruchtbaren Nährboden und den Kristallisationspunkt bieten, aber.
Das wirklich schön zu machen, das liegt eben daran, dass der Kongress nicht aus einer von konsumierenden äh konsumiert wird, sondern von Teilnehmenden gestaltet wird. Und das wird da auch nicht anders sein.
Schon immer die Versuche, dem Kongress in irgendeiner Form eine Remotekomponente hinzuzufügen. Dazu gehört natürlich äh zu Beginn vor allem erstmal.
Die Anstrengung, alles aufzuzeichnen und später die Videos zu veröffentlichen dazu und dann zunehmende Maße das Ganze eben auch live zu machen. Das funktioniert ja seit ein paar Jahren schon sehr gut.
Dann gab's eben auch so diese Möglichkeit, diesen Livetalk zu folgen und auch noch Fragen zu stellen, aber das sind natürlich alles nur so Tippe äh Schrittchen gewesen.
Und diese diese generelle Idee eines gab's ja schon auch öfter so ein bisschen äh entstanden unter diesem.
Problemdruck, dass wir eigentlich, ja, weiß ich nicht, schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren eigentlich nicht allen Leuten, die wirklich ein Ticket haben wollen, auch eins äh geben konnten.
Aber es war immer sehr schwierig, so dass das live vor Ort und und und das Remote so zusammenzubringen. Jetzt ist natürlich ganz interessant.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn's eben kein Live vor Ort gibt und das Remote in gewisser Hinsicht alles ist, was man, was man irgendwie hat, ne, hat's irgendwie.
Erfüllt es einen anderen Zweck.
Schafft es auch in irgendeiner Form das mit abzudecken, was der äh Kongress ja eigentlich macht, so gerade in den letzten Jahren hat er sich ja auch so als.
Kommunikationshub auch für,
sehr viel andere Szenen als die, die man so typischerweise einer Kerne zuschreibt, ähm herausgebildet, dass Leute einfach, ne, also
gibt der ganzen Aktivisten äh Gruppen und äh was es alles äh da in der Halle zwei äh gab, so so Inseln, die auch eigene Vortragsserien gestartet haben et cetera
und eben den Kongress so als Plattform benutzt haben, um dann ihre.
Ähm ja ihr und ihre Netzwerke weiter auszubauen und ich auch sehr gespannt, ob das da in irgendeiner Form zumindest einen Ersatz schaffen kann.
Also ich denke, man muss hier wirklich, ja, Ersatz.
Ersatzangebot, ja.
Die Frage ist mit mit welcher Erwartungshaltung gehst du da jetzt dran, ne? Äh ich denke also das kann eine schöne Zeit werden,
Ja? Aber ich glaube, ich halte es für ausgeschlossen,
mit der, mit der RC drei etwas äh entsteht, wo alle sagen, das ist so geil, wir wollen nie wieder in der Halle zurück und uns treffen,
Das wird einfach nicht sein. Also ich denke, ich hätte das ja hier auch anfangs, als es äh um die Bewertung äh der Sommeraussichten ging mit den ausfallenden äh Festivals und den geschlossenen.
Gastronomischen Einrichtungen ähm habe ich ja hier eine,
zuversichtliche ähm Note angeschlagen zu sagen, so es wird wird eben komplett anders, aber es wird auch geil. Ähm.
Zumindest hatte es das Potenzial, sagen wir es mal so. Und ich kann zumindest sagen, dass ich äh in diesem Jahr,
einige andere Aktivitäten und Freizeitaktivitäten kennen und schätzen gelernt habe, das heißt nicht, dass sich die anderen nicht vermisse, aber das heißt, äh trotzdem, dass ich hier,
halbwegs okay klargekommen bin und eigentlich eine schöne Zeit hatte. Natürlich war die anders,
und eine ein Rezept zum unglücklich und unzufrieden sein ist garantiert irgendwie zwanzig zwanzig mit zwanzig neunzehn zu vergleichen. Ähm das wird äh bei dem bei der Winter,
beim Winterevent des CCC eben äh auch nicht anders sein, nur ich denke, das Vorjahr ist hier dann eben auch die unfaire,
ähm die unfaire Vergleichsebene, ja, wenn du sagst,
Ist aber nicht so gut wie letztes Jahr, ja klar. So, daran ist aber jetzt dann, also ne, du musst natürlich schon irgendwie deine Erwartungshaltung dem anpassen, was überhaupt möglich sein kann. Und da denke ich.
Also, was man bis jetzt, der darf ja auch nicht vergessen, dass der CCC zwischen vier remote Events veranstaltet hat. Die kleinen Remote-Events, ja, ähm,
also die, die,
bei weitem nicht so eine große mediale und öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit erlangen. Die haben da ganz gut so funktioniert, das heißt wir haben jetzt auch, sage ich mal, ein Gefühl für die.
Limitierungen und ähm für die Möglichkeiten, wie man so etwas hinkriegt, natürlich mit,
vielen tausenden mehr ist da noch sehr viel mehr nötig und vor allem eben ja ein ein kreatives Geschehen, ne, dass diese ich lasse mich berieseln, Haltung wird,
wird wird da nicht so weit kommen, es wird höchstens halt gelingen, wenn man, wenn man sich überlegt, OK, wie kann ich 'ne geile Zeit haben mit,
vor Ort und Freunden Remote.
Ja, Link ist in den äh Schonaus, steht alles auf Events CCC DE, auch wie man sich da anmelden kann mit einem.
Genau, ja, vor allem, ach, da ist noch ein, ein wichtiger Punkt. Ähm, wir haben dort außerdem verlinkt, dass
das ist so ein
einfach ein ein Fragebogen, wo wo ihr mal so eure Erwartungen, Bedenken, Ideen, ja? Also wir stehen ja hier alle vor einer Herausforderung mit dieser mit dieser
mit diesem Event, mit diesem Online-Event und hm, ich habe zum Beispiel die Erfahrung, ich habe jetzt auch an dem einen oder anderen online Event teilgenommen, wo ich dann gesehen habe, ah okay,
das und das funktioniert ganz gut, das und das funktioniert nicht. Das und das war eine gute Idee, war schlecht umgesetzt, so und so könnte man's besser machen. Ja, also jede Form von,
von Feedback, die irgendwie sagt so,
jo, das ist das, das kann man eigentlich ganz gut machen, das würde ich zum Beispiel vielleicht auch machen oder so und so stelle ich mir das vor, das das sind so die Ideen, die ich dazu habe, ist für uns wichtig, um auch ein bisschen Gefühl dafür zu bekommen.
Ja, auf wie viel ähm Engagement man dann eben auch in der Community ähm zählen kann.
Und äh hoffentlich auch also da, jetzt ist da die Möglichkeit dieser ganzen Planung, diesem ganzen Geschehen dann noch den richtigen Drei im Zweifelsfall zu geben, damit das auch wirklich ein ein schönes zwischen den Jahren wird.
Genau, da würde ich euch bitten dran teilzunehmen. Ist in den Shownotes verlinkt.
So, dann äh gibt's noch ein bisschen Corona-Warn-App Aufreger.
Ja, also.
Also eine Sache von der eine Sache kann man der Corona-Warn-App ja auf jeden Fall nicht sagen, nachsagen, das wäre, dass sie besonders günstig wäre und ähm der Cem Özdemir,
hat mal die Bundesregierung gefragt, wie das denn aussieht mit einer kurdischen Version der App.
Es hat ja im September wohl gefragt, hat eine Antwort bekommen von dem Bundesministerium für Gesundheit. Sehr geehrter Herr Kollege,
ihre Frage beantworte ich wie folgt. Frage war, beabsichtigt die Bundesregierung zentrale Informationen und Instrumente zur Eindämmung der Corona-Pandemie und ihrer Folgen, wie beispielsweise die Corona-App,
kurdischer Sprache bereitzustellen und wenn nein, welcher zusätzliche Kostenaufwand wäre, dazu nach Schätzung der Bundesregierung notwendig? Antwort.
Die Bundesregierung stellt Informationen rund um die Maßnahmen zur Eindämmung des Corona-Virus-Saßhof zwei, in zahlreichen Sprachen zur Verfügung, die Corona-Warn-App ist in den Sprachen Deutsch, Englisch, Türkisch, Bulgarisch, Polnisch
und rumänisch verfügbar. An weiteren Sprachen sind ausschließlich Russisch und Arabisch in Planung,
Die Bruttokosten für weitere Sprachversionen liegen bei zweihundertfünfzigtausend Euro,
Ich ich mache das für zweihundertvierzig ehrlich gesagt. Okay, aber das steht da nicht.
Die Schätzung beruht auf den Erfahrungswerten des Robert Koch-Institutes für die Erstellung der bisherigen Sprachversionen. Die Informationen auf der Webseite WWW zusammen gegen Corona DE sind neben Deutsch auch in Englisch
Russisch und Türkisch verfügbar. Eine Übersetzung ins kurdische ist aktuell nicht beabsichtigt. Ja ähm,
Das ist natürlich ähm.
Eine überraschende Zahl, ja. Äh zweihundertfünfzigtausend Euro ist eine überraschende Zahl für eine App, deren gesamt.
Textinhalt äh ja wahrscheinlich auf eine DIN A vier Seite passt, in Schriftgröße zwölf,
und man fragt sich ja schon, ob nicht einfach mal jemand, der oder die der kurdischen Sprache mächtig ist, einfach ein auf Gitter stellen möchte und eine entsprechende Lokalisation,
ähm anbieten möchte, ja, vielleicht für moderateren, für einen moderatere Kompensation.
Ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nur vorstellen, dass der Preis so hoch ist,
weil die Telekom direkt wieder eine Hotline mit reingeschoben hat und die quasi sagen zweihundertfünfzigtausend Euro im Jahr, aber,
dann brauchen wir auch drei kurdische Mütter oder sechs kurdische Mitarbeiter, die im Schichtbetrieb ähm,
sicherstellen, dass vierundzwanzig sieben zu jeder Zeitpunkt, wenn eine kurdische Person anruft, unser Callcenter in Kurdisch arbeitet und die müssen geschult werden und technisch geschult werden und hasse alles nicht gesehen,
dass ich kann mir nicht anders erklären, wie man auf diese Zahl kommt, Tim, oder ähm oder habe ich irgendwie Übersetzung als ein als ein Business unterschätzt.
Nee, also wenn es sich dabei wirklich nur um den Text in der App handelt, dann ist das natürlich Od Radges, also das kann er
kann keiner erzählen. Ich meine, natürlich ist es immer nicht getan mit einmal übersetzen und fertig, sondern du hast ja theoretisch auch Änderungen in so einer App und dann musst du's immer wieder machen und dann brauchst du halt irgendwie jemanden, aber ich meine, dafür
kann man halt problemlos einen kurdischen Übersetzer äh engagieren und er wird sich natürlich freuen über zweihundertfünfzigtausend Euro so viel äh
werden die sicherlich äh äh sonst in ihrem Leben so nicht sehen, zumindest nicht für solche.
Dafür macht der Oma, dafür macht er auch mal noch ein Update mit, ne?
Ja, man könnte das schon ein bisschen genauer sein bei solchen Aussagen, anstatt da einfach einfach so Zahlen rauszuhauen, ne. Ja. Aber ich vermute auch, dass es solche Gründe hat.
Aber selbst wenn, also selbst wenn es ein bisschen ähm ein bisschen übertrieben und also diese Hotline ähm meint, ich habe da jetzt noch nicht angerufen.
Aber ich habe Leute in meinem Umfeld, die,
mein Handy genommen haben und da einfach mal angerufen haben und ein technisches Problem geschildert haben oder eine einfache Frage zu dieser App geschildert haben und dann auch etwas ernüchtert waren,
ähm in der Qualität der der Antwort. Es ist immer ein schlechtes Zeichen, wenn du bei der Hotline anrufst und denen das erklären muss, ne. Das ähm.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, Teil der Kosten äh hat ja auch was mit der Schulung dieser Mitarbeiter zu tun. Die müssen ja auch wissen, wovon sie reden. Ähm okay. Gut.
Das sind die, also das, denke ich, wird da auf jeden Fall mit drin sein, aber ja, äh Telefone, ne. Ich habe äh
gestern durch Zufall gesehen, es gibt noch Telefonbücher, also aktuelle, ne? Ich dachte erst boah da hat aber einer viele alte Telefonbücher weggeworfen, ne. Das waren aber die neuen Telefonbücher von zwanzigzwanzig
gibt's auch noch, na ja.
Das könnte ganz interessant sein, mal zu sehen, wer überhaupt noch im Telefonbuch steht.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein ziemlich dünnes Buch, ja. Und also für Berlin jetzt, ne, hätte ich gedacht, dass es da mehr gibt, aber ich also Telefonbuch, ne, habe ich eh nie verstanden,
Also wie wieso wieso würde ich da drin stehen wollen.
Damit du angerufen werden kannst.
Ja, ich möchte aber, ich werde ja so schon angerufen.
Ja du ja.
Das stört meistens, dass da irgendeiner Google äh äh irgendwie sagt, ich gucke mal, ich gucke mal, ach, hast du mal ein Telefonbuch von Berlin? Ich rufe mal den Linus an, ja, bitte.
Nee, das ist doch total blöd.
Also ich habe äh ich weiß noch, als ich mein erstes meine erste eigene Telefonnummer hatte, da gab's auch eben so äh wollen sie im Telefonbuch stehen? Nein, Mann, natürlich nicht. Natürlich will ich nicht im Telefonbuch stehen. Also völlig, völlig utopische,
völlig utopische Institutionen.
Ja, aber das war damals einfach anders. Also Telefonbuch, da wollte man dritt sein, weil die sollen einen sonst Leute, wie sollen sollte sonst mit einem kommunizieren?
Das war ja einfach die einzige Fernkommunikationsoption, die es überhaupt gab.
Kein Internet, nix. Also wenn du in irgendeiner Form mit Leuten in Kontakt treten willst, die nicht in deiner Straße wohnen, dann brauchtest du halt diese Zahlenreihe. Und woher solltest du die denn nehmen?
Tim, irgendwo hast du die Menschen doch kennengelernt, ne? So und dann hast du, konntest du denen deine Telefonnummer geben oder wolltest du das irgendjemand anruft?
Weil er sagt, ach hier, das ist aber interessanter Name, da mal gucken, rufe ich da mal an. Hallo, keine Gefahr.
Das kannst du dir so vorstellen, aber na ja, also das ähm ist eine andere Zeit so, das ist so wie ein nine eleven, das,
jetzt so langsam verschwindet so ein bisschen nach hinten. Du kannst dir das nicht mehr vorstellen, wie es war damals. Hast du dich über jeden Anruf gefreut?
Okay, äh machen wir mal äh weiter. Ich äh,
würde gerne nochmal darauf hinweisen. Das haben wir hier schon mal gemacht. Äh das Logbuch Netzpolitik,
auf einer Blogliste steht, die irgendein schwer erreichbarer Franzose oder Französin pflegt und die ähm von,
irgendwelchen äh Security-Bloggern, äh auch,
neben vielen anderen Listen empfohlen wird und die Leute laden die sich dann in ihr Piehol und dann äh wird Logbuch Netzpolitik geblockt, ja.
Das ist schlecht. Ja, diese Blockliste ist von allgemein schlechter Qualität, die blockt zum Beispiel auch pro Public,
wo jetzt auch klar ist, dass diese Seite nun wirklich nicht ein Tracker ist oder sonstiges,
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie wir da drauf geraten sind. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man da wieder runterkommt. Alles, was diese Person bereitstellt, ist ein Forum.
Und ich habe das Forum mal in den Shownotes verlinkt. Vielleicht äh bequemt die Person sicher,
uns wieder von dieser Blog-Liste runterzunehmen. Ansonsten kann ich nur insgesamt vor dieser Blogliste waren, also das ist die es gibt mehrere Rällblocklisten, das ist die TCM Blogliste.
In der wir da gelandet sind,
Und ja, wenn, solltet ihr Schwierigkeiten haben, dann könnt ihr äh bei euch zu Hause diese Blogliste einfach wieder aus euren DNS-Bloggern rausnehmen, bei der Arbeit, falls sie dort verwendet wird
auch mal darauf hinweisen, dass das eben eine Blockliste ist, die ähm ihre Arbeit nicht besonders ordentlich.
Zu machen scheint. Ja und wer Möglichkeit hat, Rälle zu kontaktieren, ich habe auch schon mal auf Französisch eine Nachricht dorthin geschrieben, äh kann das gerne tun, bleibt aber bitte freundlich,
ähm auch wenn das natürlich eine sehr äh ärgerliche Angelegenheit ist. Kommen wir zu den guten Nachrichten, Tim. Es gibt eine gute Nachricht.
Echt? Es gibt eine gute Nachricht. Cool.
Wie hieß nochmal dieser äh Philipp von der Bildzeitung Piatov hat eine Rüge bekommen vom Deutschen Presserat für seine äh Hetze gegen ähm,
Drosten von der Charité. Ja, da könnte man den Eindruck gewinnen, dass der Deutsche Presserat ja vielleicht äh dann hier doch ein bisschen.
Sich noch um um den guten Geschmack äh sorgt und um die Qualität der journalistischen Berichterstattung. Das ist doch mal eine,
ganz schöne Botschaft, wobei man natürlich auch sagen muss, dass dieser Deutsche Presserat, der ist ja quasi gar nichts, ne? Das ist ein ein irgendwie,
ähm Bündnis der Selbstkontrolle, wo irgendwie, ich glaube, sogar Matthias Döpfner irgendwie äh drin ist und ähm.
Gab vor kurzem einen sehr schönen.
Deutschlandfunk Hintergrund dazu, den ich auch nochmal mit in die Shownotes nehme, der quasi sagt, warum wir diesen Presserat überhaupt haben und ähm.
Was naja, dass jetzt natürlich ohne jede Konsequenz ist, ne? Da kommt dann ein kommt dann ein ein Brief, wo gesagt wird, das ist nicht gut, was du da getan hast und ähm es wird natürlich von bestimmten,
Redaktionen äh hält sich natürlich das hartnäckige Vorurteil, dass die sowas eher als Auszeichnung sehen als,
als als eine tatsächliche Rüge.
Ja, bei der Bild-Zeitung hauen sie sich das Ding noch an die Dartscheibe, also das interessiert die doch nicht.
Ja, also aber das sind ja wirklich, das ist, ist auch wirklich wieder, was hatten sie jetzt gerade wieder, dass es einfach also diese Redaktion, das ist auch also.
Alles es gibt so viele Beschreibungen, die sage ich mal versuchen.
Den Charakter dieser Redaktion irgendwie in seiner niederträchtigkeit zu beschreiben. Und alle spotten natürlich,
also alle scheitern daran, weil das was was die Bildzeitung macht einfach jeder jeder Beschreibung spottet, ne? Was haben sie diese Woche haben sie doch wieder nach einem.
Mehrfachen Mord, die WhatsApp-Nachrichten eines Elfjährigen überlebenden Kindes veröffentlicht.
Also, dass dass dieses Kind seinem seinen besten Freund geschrieben hat oder seiner besten Freundin. Das ist.
Es ist einfach, weißt du, wenn du denkst, du es geht nicht mehr niedriger als die Bild-Zeitung, dann sagen die wieder, halt mal mein Bier. Ja, und das ist.
Eine absolut unerträglich, aber die Selbstgerechtigkeit, mit der,
diese Menschen dann dann noch agieren, ja. Da da dann sollen sie eben auch diese Auszeichnungen als als,
R-Auszeichnung sehen, sie sind eben einfach nur Menschen ohne Ehre. Aber da wollte ich drauf wollte ich gar nicht hinaus. Ich wollte auf einen ganz anderen Menschen ohne Ehre eingehen,
nämlich die äh der Presserat macht diese ähm Veröffentlichung. Ich glaube, wenn ich das richtig erinnere in Erinnerung habe, die die haben nicht so oft ihre Sitzungen, ja?
Und ähm jetzt ähm mussten die auch sich damit auseinandersetzen,
der äh umstrittenen Kolumne, Abschaffung der Polizei, Allcops A Berufsunfähig, die in der Tageszeitung die TAZ veröffentlicht wurde,
ähm ein Text, der äh ja wirklich von äußerst geringer Qualität ist,
ähm sollte, glaube ich, eine Glosse sein, äh das ist der Autorin nicht, nicht besonders gelungen, aber der Deutsche Presserat ist eben nicht dafür da, ähm.
Die Qualität der Texte zu beurteilen, sondern ob sie zum Beispiel die die Meinungsfreiheit äh,
verletzen oder in diesem Fall der Vorwurf gegen die Menschenwürde, ja? Weil in diesem Text, glaube ich, stand.
Polizei kann auf den Müll oder sowas, ja? Darüber haben sich Arthe oder auf die Mülldeponie, ja?
Da hatte sich äh die Polizei drüber aufgeregt und der Innenminister.
Der ja dann unser Innenminister, Horst Seehofer, der ja dann selber noch eine Strafanzeige,
angekündigt hat und zwar nicht als Horst Seehofer Modelleisenbahner und Bayer, sondern als Bundesinnenminister.
Und nachdem jetzt der Presserat festgestellt hat, dass äh.
Dreihundertzweiundachtzig Beschwerden ähm,
Eben gegenstandslos sind und dieser Text äh ein drastisches Gedankenspiel darstellt, dass aber wie aus der Kolumne hervorgeht, Raum für unterschiedliche Interpretationen bietet und daher noch unter die Meinungsfreiheit fällt.
Das hat also jetzt der der Presserat bekundet und da hat sich wie der, wie der, der deutsche Innenminister.
Mit einer äh Pressemeldung an die Öffentlichkeit gewendet und den Presserat gerügt.
Also der Bundesinnenminister rückt den Presserat, weil der Presserat nicht,
eine die meinen ein Text nicht gerückt hat, weil er unter die Meinungsfreiheit fällt. Das finde ich äh,
Ich finde das äh wirklich bärenstark, ja, dass das ist äh also Horst Seehofer wirklich da merkt man, der Mann wird,
Also der ist sehr, sehr eigentümlich und ziemlich alt und ist da glaube ich in einer äh in einer Rolle ähm mit.
Er sehr schaden kann,
Ja und äh also einerseits der Rolle des Innenministers und andererseits auch natürlich so dem generellen Verständnis von Demokratie in Deutschland
Und da ist Horst Seehofer wirklich eine ganz, ganz katastrophale Fehlbesetzung, muss ich wirklich sagen.
Wird langsamer Zeit, dass wenn äh CSU Bundeskanzler bekommen.
Weil dann können sie das Innenministerium und wahrscheinlich auch das Verkehrsministerium nicht mehr verunzen. Äh ich meine, das ist doch wirklich nur drittklassiges Personal, was sie da äh in den letzten Jahren aufgefahren haben.
Ja
Unglaublich. Na ja, also das, da, das war, dazu hatte der Zeit, er hat das übrigens veröffentlicht, diese Meldung, äh, diese Pressemitteilung mit seinem Statement an dem Tag,
an dem der äh Brand in Moria eigentlich das,
bestimmende Thema war, ne? Wir wissen Moria auf äh Lesbos eine,
ähm ja, ich denke, da kann man wirklich sagen, ein Lager, ein völlig überfülltes Lager mit geflüchteten Menschen. Seit ähm vielen Monaten in der schärfsten Kritik,
aufgrund der äh absoluten Überfüllung katastrophalen, hygienischen Umstände in Zeiten einer globalen Pandemie.
Regelmäßig angegriffen von irgendwelchen rechtsradikalen äh Griechen, die da äh.
Die meinen, dass das Lager irgendwie angreifen zu müssen, während ganz Europa dasteht und sagt, naja, nö, also die sind ja jetzt in Griechenland angekommen, das ist ja, sind ja nicht unser Problem, ja. Und an dem Tag, als hier ein Brand auslöst, äh äh ein ein Brand,
die Menschen aus diesem Lager äh zu, also sie muss quasi aus dem brennenden Lager fliehen,
wurden auf der anderen Seite von der griechischen Polizei mit Tränengasgranaten beschossen, während sie vor Feuer geflohen sind, wurden sie also von der griechischen Polizei mit mit äh mit ähm.
Tränengasgranaten wieder in Richtung des Feuers getrieben, ja? An diesem Tag hat äh Horst Seehofer nichts anderes zu tun, als sich über irgendein bescheuerten Text in der TAZ,
auszulassen. Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dieser Text war,
ist einer der schlechtesten Texte, die ich je gelesen habe. Ja, und genau deshalb äh finde ich es auch so,
traurig, so absolut traurig, dass wir einen Innenminister haben, der dafür seine Zeit verschwendet und damit diesen Text aufhört, aufwertet und würdigt, ja? Ähm das ist äh wirklich,
ähm das ist wirklich eine sehr traurige Angelegenheit. Ich habe gerade hier die Push-Nachricht bekommen, dass Horst Seehofer angekündigt hat, äh,
irgendwie, ich glaube, hundertfünfzig Kinder aus Moria aufzunehmen zum Vergleich in diesem Lager sind, glaube ich, äh über dreizehntausend Menschen, ja. Das ist.
Und der will mir einen von Würde erzählen. Das ist äh unterhaltsam.
Ja, immerhin.
Mensch und Christ werde ich solch eine solche Sprache niemals akzeptieren. Ja dann oh man, da ist er wirklich Beleidigung für alle Christen, aber das müssen die Christen unter sich ausmachen.
Hier lese ich gerade einen lustigen Tweet dazu. Seehofer nimmt hundertfünfzig Flüchtlinge auf, aber erst an seinem hundertfünfzigsten Geburtstag.
Ausgerechnet da in meinem hundertfünfzigsten Geburtstag werden. Hundertfünfzig, das war von mir nicht so bestellt, Personen eingeführt. Das liegt weit über dem, was bisher üblich war. Ja.
Oh man, er äh Referenzen natürlich zu seinem Ding, wo er noch irgendwie gesagt hat, weil das ja noch irgendwie gefeiert hat, dass an seinem Geburtstag hundert Leute.
Zu viel ausgewiesen wurden, ja.
Meinem Geburtstag das ist wirklich,
Der ist peinlich. Das ist wirklich peinlich. Da muss da muss mal was passieren. Was auch peinlich war, war der, wie hieß der jetzt eigentlich? Alarmtag war gestern, war der Sirenentag oder wie hieß das denn?
Alarm.
War der Hashtag.
Weiß nicht, ob an diesem Tag äh überhaupt nicht groß kommuniziert, weil ich irgendwie die ganze Zeit nur unterwegs war. Aber bundesweite Alarmtag war, glaube ich, so der äh Begriff, unter dem das.
Es war der der Bundes. So und was haben sie, also die Idee war, wir haben ja in Deutschland das äh.
Äh Moment, BM.
Bundesministerium, Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe BBK, Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe. So, die.
Ähm sind damit äh sind dafür da, dass wir dass die Bevölkerung geschützt wird und bei Katastrophen geholfen wird. Ähm eine.
Eine Einrichtung, die zu Zeiten des Kalten Krieges noch sehr viel größer war, ne, also,
ja man die in der gesamt die ganze Zeit in der Angst lebte, dass äh uns hier bald die Atom-Eier auf den Kopf geworfen werden und dann hatte man überall Sirenen
Ja, und die wurden auch regelmäßig geprüft, ja? Ich bin auch ganz überrascht, dass das nicht mehr stattfindet. Also, ich erinnere das aus meiner Kindheit auf jeden Fall auch, dass es da irgendwie, ich glaube, das war samstags um zwölf,
wurden die Sirenen getestet. Er war einfach so. Kannst du dich da auch.
Ja, also es wurde, ich kann mich auch eindeutig mehr Tests erinnern, aber nicht nicht jede Woche.
Ich meine, das war äh wöchentlich.
Übrigens hieß es bundesweiter Warntag. Nicht Alarm.
Bundesweite Warntag.
Ja, da sollte gewarnt werden. Warnen scheint ja überhaupt so ein sehr beliebtes Wort zu sein in der Bundesregierung und Verwaltung. Warn-App war ein Tag.
Ja, aber hat nicht so funktioniert mit dem wahren Tag, weil die Sirenen waren wohl nicht so, ich weiß nicht, ich war gerade auf der Autobahn, deswegen habe ich das überhaupt nicht zur Kenntnis genommen, was da irgendwie hast du was gehört?
Also hier nein, ich habe auch nichts gehört, aber hier in Berlin äh gibt's auch gar keine Sirenen mehr, habe ich äh verstanden. Mh.
Es ist also es gibt da ein ein relativ interessantes, aufschlussreiches Interview mit dem Herrn Unger. Der Herr Unger ist der ähm.
Chef.
Der Präsident des Bundesamts für Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe. Vorher war er in Niedersachsen äh im Bundesinnenministerium für Zivilschutz und Katastrophenlagen zuständig. So, der ähm,
hat also äh hier sich,
da mal so ein bisschen über die Warnkapazitäten der Bundesrepublik Deutschland auch hier gesprochen in diesem Spiegel-Interview, weil sagt so, ja, Sirene,
ist äh relativ blöd, weil die sagt, die macht ja nur tut, sagt ihr, es gibt eine Gefahr, aber sie sagt dir nicht.
Welche, ja? Und deswegen bedienen sie äh Rundfunk, Fernsehen,
Presseagenturen, Apps, digitale Werbetafeln in den Städten, äh sie wollen in Zukunft auch auf Navigationsgeräte,
oder Laternen irgendwie zu äh steuern können, dass die Laternen rot leuchten und die Navigationsgeräte haben offenbar,
auch eine nicht spezifizierte Art der Notfall äh Bewahrung, ja und ähm.
Er erkennt durchaus an, dass eben auch viele ältere Leute eben kein äh Smartphone, Smartphone haben,
Ähm was man jetzt festgestellt hat, ist außerdem, die haben tatsächlich das wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht so blöd. Die haben kein einzelnen Knopf.
Wo man drauf drucken kann, sondern die müssen natürlich mit den Leitstellen der unterschiedlichen.
Länder und Metropolregionen irgendwie kommunizieren, weshalb es eben auch jetzt offenbar zu diesem Testtag kam, ja? Und.
Jetzt ist Folgendes passiert. Der größere Teil dieser Sirenen, die hast du gar nicht gehört. Es kursieren oft Twitter. Auch Videos von kaputten Sirenen, die dann.
Sehr ähm bemitleidenswerte äh Geräusche machen. Und besonders äh nicht funktioniert, haben offenbar die,
Apps, ja? Und da gibt es ja diese App äh Nina und Katwan sind, glaube ich, die die berühmteren.
Die Berühmterin, die Nina ist die offizielle Warn-App der ähm der Bundesregierung oder also des des Bundes und Katwan ist eine Warn-App, der des Bundes der deutschen Versicherer.
Aha, okay. Weißt du, was Nina gekostet hat?
Die hatten da früher so viel wie eine kurdische Übersetzung oder.
Nein, nein, nein, so viel wie eine Corona-App. Äh zwanzig Millionen. Zwanzig Millionen.
Aber sie hat Probleme, das zu tun, wenn man also wenn man sie mal braucht, das dann auch zu tun.
Was mich jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt nicht wundert, denn jetzt gucken wir mal, also was du ja hier hast, ist eine Situation, in der du ähm Kommunikation machen möchtest, ne. Und,
ähm eine App mit einer Push-Notification.
Ist dafür nicht geeignet. Warum? Weil der Aufwand zum Versenden des Alarms mit der Anzahl der Empfängerinnen linear skaliert.
Und ein äh sauberes Medium, wie zum Beispiel das Radio.
Ähm hat dieses Problem nicht. Ja, also ein Radio,
Sendemast wird nicht stärker belastet, weil mehr Menschen das Radiosignal empfangen. Und diese Push-Nachrichten,
Sache hat ja dann noch den, sage ich mal, in Deutschland noch das besondere Problem, dass man hier auf eine sehr.
Löchrige Infrastruktur setzt, die viele Flächen des Landes überhaupt nicht erschlossen hat, ja. Und da wurde halt der gute Herr Unger hier gefragt.
Im Spiegel. Ähm in anderen Ländern erhält man bei Gefahrenlagen automatisch eine Handynachricht.
Wenn man sich in einer bestimmten Gegend aufhält. Und der antwortet der gute Herr Unger, ja,
Die Niederlande zum Beispiel setzen auf dieses Broadcast System. Wird derzeit aber von keinem deutschen Mobilfunkanbieter angeboten,
und steht daher zu Zwecken der Bevölkerungswarnung hierzulande aktuell nicht zur Verfügung. Außerdem hat er dann gesagt,
dass äh und dieser Teil wurde inzwischen korrigiert, dass er sagt, dieses Broadcast System hätte.
Datenschutzprobleme, weil man damit ja jedes Handy anspricht und außerdem würde man ja an Silvester immer sehen, wenn das.
Handynetz überlastet ist, dass das nicht zuverlässig funktioniert. Und das sagt dieser Mann.
Verteidigung eines App-Systems, was darauf passiert, dass du eine,
Puschmeldung, über genau dieses Mobilfunknetz bekommen muss. Jetzt schauen wir uns mal an, was ist, Broadcast ist ein ähm Standard, der schon seit äh
ich würde jetzt sagen neunziger Jahre, äh irgendwo spezifiziert wurde ähm und zwar äh schon zu zu GSM Zeiten. Wäre jetzt so meine äh grobe,
Erinnerung. Und der funktioniert so, dass nämlich die Zelle, also wir wissen ja, eine,
Mobilfunknetz besteht aus Zellen, die Zelle sendet jetzt eine
Message, Broadcast heißt immer Rundfunk, also sie sendet nicht spezifisch an jedes eingebuchte Mobiltelefon
sondern sie sendet quasi als Zelle immer so ein Biegen, den alle in dieser Zelle eingebuchten Telefone automatisch M
fangen können. Das Ding kann.
Weil es eben dann quasi der Aufwand immer nur Prozelle ist ähm gibt's so irgendwie die äh die neuesten Generationen können so in einem Netz von einer Millionen Zellen.
In weniger als zehn Sekunden diese eine Nachricht verbreiten, ja? Und damit quasi das gesamte Mobilfunknetz ähm.
Erreichen. Insbesondere ist,
da ist eine Broadcast-Nachricht ist, dass genau nicht ein Datenschutzproblem, weil es im Prinzip heißt, deine Zelle sendet einfach nur dieses Signal, ja? Sie sie sendet das nicht an dein Handy, dein Handy bestätigt nicht den Empfang,
Mobilfunknetz weiß zwar, dass du in der Zelle bist, aber das,
Das BBK muss das hier nicht irgendwie mitgeteilt bekommen oder sowas, ja. Das ist das, was man, wofür man das haben möchte. Ja, das ist genau, dafür wurde das auch erfunden und mir ist völlig unklar.
Warum ähm warum wir das in Deutschland nicht haben.
Ja, also das ist für mich auch der totale Schocker. Also ich wäre davon ausgegangen, dass es das gibt. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich meine mich auch erinnern zu können, mal so eine Nachricht ähm empfangen zu haben. Ich kann bloß nicht mehr genau sagen, wann.
Bestimmten Mobilfunk
Anbietern. Ähm ich weiß aber jetzt nicht mehr genau, welcher das war, aber äh da kannst du auch anmachen und dann Broadcast die Zelle irgendwie ihre Sell-ID,
Ja, dass äh da bin ich aber jetzt nicht mehr genau sicher, an bei welchem äh ähm Anbieter das war. Ähm die können natürlich unterschiedliche.
Nachrichten senden, ne? Also du kannst irgendwie eine Standardnachricht, eine Alarmnachricht und so weiter. Das ist alles schön ordentlich,
durchgespeckt, wie das eben so ist bei äh äh drei GPP Standards, ne? Ich sehe hier gerade erste Demonstration, ja Ende der Neunziger, ne.
Hm und da fragst du dich ernsthaft, wie jemand, der dem Bundesamt für,
Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe vorsitzt
nicht weiß und da irgendwie eine derart also dass der sich dann noch berichtigen lassen muss, äh berichtigen muss in seinem eigenen Artikel, irgendwas von Datenschutz redet und in einem Satz sagt, naja, manchmal funktioniert das nur Mobilfunknetz nicht.
Ähm dann haben wir ein Problem, deswegen machen wir lieber eine App mit einer Notification übers Mobilfunknetz. Das ist schon echt äh ganz schön traurig. Ähm zumal.
Bin ich jetzt auf dünnem Eis, ja, aber ich würde sogar sagen, ja, so wie ich diese
Standards mir anschaue und wie das funktioniert. Das Problem, wenn du eine, wenn eine Mobilfunkzelle überlastet ist und du nicht mehr telefonieren kannst, ist, dass du im Prinzip nicht mehr ein,
spezifische ein spezifisches Kontext, eine Session für dich herstellen kannst, ja? Wo du dann deinen timestot hast und in dem mit dieser Zelle funkst, weil die eben überlastet ist.
Broadcast-Nachricht sollte davon immer noch unberührt sein. Das heißt, da solange die Zelle diese Broadcast-Nachricht sendet und das Telefon.
An dieser Zelle lauert, wird es diese Broadcast-Nachricht bekommen. Also auch, ich denke, dass der bei sauberer Implementierung.
Zumindest du gute Chancen hast, dass das sogar bei einer für, sagen wir mal, Telefonie und Netz,
überlasteten Zelle immer noch zuverlässig funktioniert.
Ja, es gibt ja verschiedene Stufen auch der Überlastung. Also die eine Überlastung, die er da,
angesprochen hat, mit ja Silvester und so weiter, sind die Netze überlastet, weil da viele gleichzeitig telefonieren wollen und dann hängt das natürlich äh von den äh sogenannten Erlangen,
die deine Zelle hat, also wie viele, also Erlangen ist die Einheit für wie viele parallele,
Telefonie, Durchleitung kann es gleichzeitig geben, ja, wenn die natürlich erreicht ist, dann,
man nicht mehr durch. Ja, die nächste Stufe der Überlastung ist, dass die Zelle
gar nicht mehr in der Lage ist, mit allen Telefonen den Kontakt zu halten, die jetzt irgendwo sind. Das hat man eher, wenn es irgendwo eine größere Veranstaltung gibt.
Wo eine Zelle steht, die,
Solche Menschenmassen noch nie gesehen hat und darauf in irgendeiner Form nicht vorbereitet oder ausgelegt ist, sagen wir mal, du hast irgendwo eine Party irgendwo oder so eine Demonstration äh an einem Ort
noch nie eine Demonstration gesehen hat und das läuft aus dem Ufer. Das dürfte aber schon eher relativ selten sein und natürlich, egal, wie diese Auslastung äh ist,
alles, was irgendwie an der Zelle angemeldet ist, ähm müsste diesen Broadcast erreichen,
und von daher äh gibt's wahrscheinlich kaum etwas Effizienteres, eine digitale Information zuzustellen in Deutschland.
Nee, also genau und wie gesagt, hier handelt es sich um eine Broadcast-Nachricht.
Dass es auf einem Kanal äh jedes Handy weiß das, standardisiert, spezifiziert kommen die CB Nachrichten, ja und äh das ist äh tatsächlich etwas, was du,
wofür da das Telefon nicht großartig da mit der mit der mit der Nachricht kommunizieren muss, es ist eben
Broadcast. Und ich denke, ähm das ist das ist das Entscheidende, warum man sich mal ähm.
Auch wenn ich das inzwischen, auch wenn man das inzwischen irgendwie nicht mehr macht, ja? Und alle irgendwie über Internet streamen
Deswegen hat man irgendwann mal Broadcast-Systeme gemacht. Deswegen können wir mit Satelliten fernsehen, äh ohne dass der Satellit überlastet wird. Deswegen können wir Radio hören oder ist der Radiosender überlastet wird,
und genau in diesem Sale YouLan Network wurde eben auch gesagt, na komm, dann machen wir wenigstens auf auf Zellebene nochmal ein Broadcast Standard,
um solche Notifications raussenden zu können. Und ja, ist also wirklich völlig.
Es gibt also fairerweise muss man sagen.
Klar, man kriegt das rausgesendet und dann auch angezeigt. Ich meine, mich zu erinnern, wie das so auf so einem iPhone aussieht. Das äh kommt ganz anders rüber als in normale Nachricht, die man bekommt. Also es ist.
Auf dem Display angeze.
Genau, das ist nicht so eine SMS oder so, dass dann irgendwie deine Nachrichten-App aufgeht und das dann schön irgendwie mit grünen Bubbles anzeigt, sondern
ja, das ist so wie so ein Overlay über alles, das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass diese Nachricht in dem Sinne nur auf dem Bildschirm steht, nicht äh
im Kontext einer App weiterführende Informationen haben kann, ne, also so was wie einen Link und eine genauere Erläuterung oder eine Karte oder was weiß ich, was man halt gemeinhin auch heutzutage so erwarten würde und ja auch von dieser Nina
App in der Regel auch so geliefert bekommen. Das ist natürlich da nicht machbar. Aber
Digitales zu der Sirene, die ja jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel Meta-Informationen äh hat, außer,
wie oft sie in welcher Reihenfolge wie vor sich hin heult, ja?
Was ja heutzutage auch äh keiner drauf hat. Also ich weiß nicht, ob du sagen könntest, welches Sirenensignal jetzt, welche welches Maß an Gefahr anzeigt, ne.
Weißt du, wo das steht, Tim?
Wikipedia steht das natürlich.
Nee, hinten auf dem Telefonbuch.
Hinterm Telefonbuch steht, wie die Sirenensignale sind.
Ja. Ja.
Ernsthaft? Wow. Das ist aber deswegen, dafür sind die da.
Also zumindest war das früher so. Ich weiß, also äh ich äh äh steht auch hier in diesem wirklich sehr unterhaltsamen Interview mit dem Herrn Unger. Hm aber äh der sagt, er steht hinten aufm Telefonbuch, ja.
Also Alarm tun ist.
Kann ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt nicht so auf die Stelle verifizieren?
Also der normale Alarmton bei der Sirene ist eine Minute auf und abschwellender Heulton, ist so Alarm, ja? Und wenn's nur so zwölf Sekunden dauert Ton ist, dann äh wird nur die freiwillige Feuerwehr alarmiert.
Machen das wahrscheinlich aber auch mittlerweile mit der App und deswegen brennt jetzt alles ab.
Ich meine so, ja, hast du ja auch noch das Problem, dass die Telefone auch in so Ruhe ähm.
Zuständen sich gerade befinden können. So hier störe mich nicht pipapo, also so richtig alarmierend ist es halt äh auch nicht.
Sorry, dass das kannst du nicht wegschalten. Tim, die Standards von der äh drei GP sind schon sehr ordentlich, ja? Und wenn da
eine äh Zellen äh Broadcast-Nachricht äh Katastrophe kommt, dann sag nicht dein iPhone, nee störe mich jetzt nicht.
Es zeigt den Text an, aber es äh weckt mich ja nicht auf. Fängt ja nicht an, äh einen Sirenenton abzuspielen.
Doch natürlich kann es auch piepen, natürlich. Ja klar.
Ja? Okay, gut, das wäre dann ein Argument dafür. Ich äh bezog mich jetzt eben auch grade äh auf die Apps, also dass die sozusagen, wenn man die Apps.
Nein, nein, also wird auch wird auch in,
vielen Ländern eingesetzt. Also er hat jetzt hier Niederlande gesagt, gibt noch viele andere Länder, die das die das benutzen. Also, das ist und noch dazu.
Also das ist ein ein Widerspruch äh Interview ohne Ende. Dann sagt der Evi, ja viele ältere Leute haben ja kein Smartphone, genau. Aber solange die ein Handy haben, äh was sie nach sagen wir mal neunzehnhundertachtundneunzig gekauft haben
dann kann ihr Telefon dieses Nachrichten empfangen.
Sogar ohne Apps.
Sogar ohne App.
Ist halt äh Teil des Standards. Kriegst das Gerät auch nicht äh irgendwie, wahrscheinlich darfst du halt nicht verkaufen, wenn du äh Standard nicht nicht erfüllst. Ne, also du das musst du halt können.
Na ja, aber die Schwablerfraktion hat uns ja schon davon in Kenntnis gesetzt, dass dieser ganze Warntag und die ganzen Sirenen ja nur äh dazu waren, um uns irgendwie aus der Ferne zu steuern und irgendwas zu aktivieren.
Insofern vielleicht ganz gut, dass die Sirenen nicht so losgegangen sind, ne? Sonst wären wir jetzt alle ferngesteuert.
Das werden wir jetzt alles hergesteuert. Das wäre natürlich auch ein Problem gewesen. Ja. Wir haben ähm natürlich auch wieder noch netzpolitischere Themen. Es gibt ähm eine.
Ausnahmsweise mal Politik, jetzt auch mit Netzpolitik.
Die Burn, die Bundesregierung, die Europäische Kommission.
Sie müsse sich jetzt damit auseinandersetzen, dass es ja so viel Verschlüsselung gibt. Und ähm wir wissen ja, es gibt immer zwei wichtige Themen, die äh,
Verschlüsselung ins Feld geführt werden, dass es entweder Terrorismus oder dokumentierte Kindesmisshandlung.
Und jetzt wird äh die EU-Kommission in dieser Hinsicht, also aktiv, sagen, na, ich erinnere daran, seit zwanzig sechzehn
ist endet zu Ende verschlüsselung in die Breite gegangen, spezifisch bei äh WhatsApp war das der Fall, die damals gesagt haben, okay wir rollen jetzt die.
Signal Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung bei uns aus und lassen halt mal diese Nachrichten äh verschlüsselt ähm.
Ähm ja, vor unserem Blick geschützt und.
Jetzt wird äh nahegelegt, dass es äh pädokriminelle gibt, die das nutzen. Ich halte das für eine enorm schlechte Idee.
Äh das mit einem solchen Messenger zu machen, ähm weil rucki zucki,
solche Bilder dann auch in was weiß ich in die iCloud oder in die Googlefotos oder sonst was geschossen werden. Also ich halte das
für grundsätzlich keine besonders gute Idee und kann mir deshalb nicht unbedingt vorstellen, dass das so verbreitet ist. Ähm zumindest, sagen wir mal so,
oder sagen wir mal so, wenn es verbreitet ist, dann unter denen, die auch erwischt und verhaftet werden. Es gibt da jetzt, glaube ich, grade auch so ein Fußballspieler, der,
ähm,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen offenbar für eine gute Idee hielt, solche Sachen über WhatsApp zu versenden und dann noch an Menschen, die das nicht haben wollten. Mir ist auch nicht ganz klar, was ihnen.
Was ihn da äh angeleitet hat. Jedenfalls dieses.
Problem, dass also nun eine Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung in der Kommunikation stattfindet, damit potenziell illegale Inhalte versendet werden können, möchten sie jetzt angehen,
indem man eine äh technische Lösung findet, die endet zu Ende Schlüsselung zu,
bewahren und trotzdem den Tausch illegaler Inhalte zu unterbinden. Ja.
Ähm das ist wieder dieses klassische, ne, wir hätten gerne äh wir hätten gerne den Keks, wir würden den Keks gerne behalten und ihn essen.
Und äh das äh geht natürlich nicht. Aber, sagen wir mal so, jetzt gibt es hier ein Paper, in dem sie ähm.
Unterschiedliche Regelungen, sowohl der gesellschaftlichen als auch der technischen Seite versuchen.
Zu beschreiben, ja, dass Paper äh ist geliebt,
und das steht schon direkt oben drauf,
Also das ist hier nicht unsere Meinung, wir haben das nur mal anfertigen lassen, diese achtundzwanzig Seiten, wo ähm viele.
Leute von Google, Microsoft.
Ähm paar Universitäten und unterschiedlichen Polizeibehörden,
unter anderem auch äh Geheimdienste wie GCAQ beteiligt waren, die sich also quasi hier und das finde ich immer sehr,
Also da da sieht man, wie so Diskussionen laufen. Da werden einfach mal alle Möglichkeiten hingestellt.
Und dann wird,
Sie bereit äh bewertet in diesem Fall nach Effektivität, Durchführbarkeit, Privacy, Security und Transparency,
ja? Und sagen ähm aha, das sind das sind die die Optionen, die es gibt,
Ja und jetzt machen wir mal, wer jetzt bewerten wir die einfach mal, ja? Wo wo natürlich die Option, das einfach mal nicht zu machen, nicht mehr drin vorkommt. Ja, und dann werden drei top Lösungen identifiziert.
Ähm die sind ähm,
On-Device Full-Hashing with matching server. Mit anderen Worten, das bedeutet, ähm dein, also jede Datei,
die du durch diesen Messenger sendest oder empfängst, von der wird eine Prüfsumme errechnet und jetzt.
Dein Gerät mit einem zentralen Server und sagt, ich habe hier eine Datei mit folgender Prüfsumme, ist die.
Böse oder nicht. Und dann bekommt es die Antwort zum Beispiel, ja die ist böse und dann muss es,
eben darauf reagieren im Zweifelsfall die Datei löschen oder äh was oder was auch immer, ne, hier für Möglichkeiten im Raum stehen. Es könnte natürlich auch sofort der Polizei sagen, hier übrigens,
Nutzer XY hat eine solche Datei gehabt. Ich habe die jetzt mal gelöscht oder Beweis äh sicher äh gespeichert, ja?
Also sie reagiert, die App reagiert irgendwie da drauf. Dann haben sie gesagt, okay.
Der andere Top drei Einsatz wäre. Ich vermute, dass sie damit etwas äh meinen wie du ähm.
Du berechnest den ganzen Hash.
Fragst aber den Server nur sagen wir mal nach den nach den paar Anfangsbuchstaben deines. Der Surfer gibt dir alle.
Hashes die so anfangen und dadurch verrätst du dem Server nicht,
welche ob du die Datei tatsächlich hattest oder nicht. Also im Prinzip so ein bisschen Doppelblind, ja? Wo sie sagen, das ist hier noch noch äh äh Prime noch private und dann haben sie noch irgendwie eine Idee, ähm.
Die ähm.
Mit einer Secure Endlave in einem ESP-Server funktionieren soll, wo es also auch ein äh.
Ja, das versuche ich hier gerade mir nochmal so anzuschauen. Ähm sie wollen äh mit Humor verschlüsselung arbeiten und ähm.
Letztendlich, ich glaube, dass muss ich tatsächlich sagen, da ist mir nicht ganz klar.
Eier, okay. Alles klar. Also, es gibt einen Server und der Server entschlüsselt einfach deine Nachricht. Ja? Checkt, ob da irgendwas Böses drin ist und wenn ähm.
Dass ähm festgestellt wird, dann wird es äh weitergeleitet. For Review and Reporting. Und wenn nichts detected wird, dann wird die Nachricht wieder Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt und dem,
Empfänger gegeben. Ja, also da sagen sie im Prinzip, wir haben einen einen Server, an den du immer mit,
verschlüsselt, der hat aber eine Secure and Clave äh und die kann ähm.
Diese diese die macht diesen Test in der Cloud. Also kommen sie einfach ein paar Passwörter draufgeworfen für letztendlich ein Mann in the mittel, ja? Ähm.
In der Cloud das klingt,
nicht richtig. Also wer nicht ganz folgen kann, Secure And Clave ist gemeinhin die Bezeichnung für so einen äh.
Ja, so einen isolierten Ort in einem Prozessor, in dem ein Programm läuft mit seinen eigenen Daten, mit dem man nur über so ein Protokoll,
kommunizieren kann, aber indem man nicht reinschreiben kann oder so. Und äh da werden dann zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, Pins und so weiter äh äh abgelegt,
Oder wenn du so einen Computer hast mit Fingerabdruck, äh Sensor oder Gesichtserkennung, dann wird sozusagen das Profil dort gespeichert, damit eben Programme dann normalerweise nicht drauf zugreifen können, aber wenn das dann irgendwie in der Cloud ist, dann ist es schon wieder alles vorbei.
Also sie die.
In der Regel nimmst du so etwas damit Schlüsselmaterial nicht kopiert werden kann, ne? Also das sensitive Daten äh wie Schlüssel angewendet werden können, aber nicht,
kopiert werden können. Und da würden sie jetzt irgendwie sagen, in der Cloud gibt's irgendwie einen Server und die ja, da die Secure NC soll das jetzt, also haarsträubend, ja? Letztendlich bedeutet das,
Sie wollen, Sie suchen hier nach verschiedenen Methoden. Ich hab jetzt mal drei geschildert von, ich glaub das waren um die zehn.
Drei, sieben, elf. Ähm.
Die sie hier identifiziert haben, wo sie sagen, ja so könnte man das eigentlich machen, weil man da ja dann doch relativ viel Privatsphäre behält. Wir wir entschlüsseln das ja nur Secure,
Und äh und und und führen die Nachricht ansonsten ab, dass es im Prinzip, dass äh das einfache Verfahren, ne? Das bedeutet, du hast du verschlüsselt hier die Nachricht auch immer noch mal mit
an den Sensor und der kann da der kann reinschauen. So äh langer Rede kurzer Sinn.
Das sind alles nicht besonders gute Ideen, weil, was am Ende passieren wird, ist doch relativ simpel Folgendes.
Ähm stell dir mal vor, das ist tatsächlich inzwischen glücklicherweise durchaus auch üblich, so geliebte Dokumente werden gerne mal mit, zum Beispiel, Signal versendet.
Wo man sagt, ah hier, guck dir das mal an, schau da mal drauf, gib mir doch mal bitte deinen äh deinen O-Ton, deinen Eindruck dazu, ja? Jetzt stell dir vor, jeder Messenger würde immer von jeder Datei, mehr oder weniger den,
verraten, die er empfangen hat. Das ist ähm solange du den Dateiinhalt nicht kennst, kein Problem,
Wenn du aber auf der Suche nach einer spezifischen Datei bist, eben doch relativ einfach möglich. Das heißt, was du natürlich als nächstes hättest wäre, dass du sagst, hör mal, die Anfragen, die an den Server gehen, ne,
wollen wir aber mal bitte locker äh die wollen wir mal bitte loggen, damit wenn sich die Datei später als illegal rausstellt, wir trotzdem schon mal wissen, wer die hat,
ja? Und,
dann hättest du eben beispielsweise bei anderen Materialien, die Horst Seehofer vielleicht gerade für der Menschenwürde der Polizei nicht zuträglich hält, eben auch ähm Aufzeichnungen und Kanäle dazu,
Der andere Punkt ist, in dem Moment, wo du so etwas äh implementierst oder rechtlich verpflichtend machst, wandern alle Kriminellen ab auf,
ein System, was diesen Nachteil für ihre Interessen nicht hat und.
Die einzigen, die am Ende geschädigt sind von deinem System, sind die ganz normalen arglosen Nutzer, die in einer Welt voller Facebooks und TikToks und äh Trackern und Googles und,
Corona Restaurantlisten, die nicht ordentlich gesichert sind, wenigstens mal eine kleine Kurznachricht,
eine Freundin schicken wollen, ohne dass die Regierung oder irgendein Konzern mitließt. Das sind dann die,
Leidtragenden. Gibt diesen alten Satz, den ich hier im Logbuch auch schon öfter gesagt habe, wenn du.
Die Privatsphäre kriminalisierst, dann haben eben noch kriminelle Privatsphäre und genau das ist ja,
nun mal nicht Ziel der Angelegenheit. Aber das ist äh das, wo es hingeht und so, wie man sich das jetzt hier,
wie wie sich das liest, kannst du dir schon vorstellen, dass die EU Kommission das jetzt wieder zu ihrem größten Problem macht,
und sich meint darum kümmern zu müssen, ja? Während das, was eigentlich, sage ich mal, relevant ist in dieser Gesellschaft,
völlig im völlig in in der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet, ohne irgendwelche Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung, äh irgendwelche Nazikanäle auf Telegramm, äh wo keiner was von wusste
wo sie dann überrascht sind, dass irgendwo ein Sturm auf den Reichstag stattgefunden hat, ja? Also ich, es ist, es ist.
Die suchen sich einfach diese technischen Probleme habe ich inzwischen den Eindruck, gezielt heraus, um von ihrer tatsächlichen fachlichen.
Inkompetenz, in der Polizeiarbeit und in den blind Spots, die nicht technisch sind, sondern in ihren Köpfen abzulenken. Ich kann mir das anders nicht mehr erklären.
Schwierig, das anders zu deuten.
Na ja, ich meine, keine Ahnung, fühle ich mich dadurch bedroht? Naja, weißt du, wenn sie das jetzt irgendwie, wenn sie die uns die Ende äh zu Ende Verschlüsselung in den großen Messenger wieder wegnehmen? Dann nehmen wir eben andere, die vernünftige Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung haben. Und dann, dann versuchen sie, uns die zu verbieten,
Also diese diese Kryptowars, jedes, jede Woche neu anfangen zu wollen mit jede Woche neuen ähm.
Komischen ähm Vorwänden, ja? Äh finde ich tatsächlich ziemlich ermüdend. Tja.
Genauso ermüdend wie das Dauerthema Digitalisierung des Unterrichts.
Digitalisierung des Unterrichts. Das ist äh das ist wirklich ermüdend. Das ist ja auch wirklich abgefahren das Thema, das ist durch äh.
Wobei Steffen Seibert äh der Cyber-Beauftragte, der Cyber-Regierung ja kürzlich noch twitterte, äh Digitalisierungsnot-Dat. Aber ich würde sagen, in Deutschland stinkt sie auf jeden Fall schon mal relativ übel.
Ähm dass ähm.
Gibt also jetzt irgendwie den Digitalpakt, wo dann irgendwie mal wieder fünfhundert Millionen Euro für Laptops, für Schülerinnen zu kaufen sein sollen, äh dann legte der Bund nochmal was drauf und wir kennen die Geschichten mit diesen Laptops, die liegen dann.
In der Regel.
Auf einmal äh liegen dann irgendwo und können nicht eingerichtet werden oder haben kein Internet oder sonst was. Also gab's jetzt noch die Idee.
Man könnte doch den Schülerinnen aus den benachteiligten Familien.
So ein Internettarif, so ein Bildungs äh äh Internettarif geben. Und zwar für zehn Euro pro Monat, eine Flatrate auf ausgewählte Bildungsinhalte.
Und die können dann in die geförderten Endgeräte aus dem Digitalpakt kommen,
und dann können die Schülerinnen aber nur auf Bildungsinhalte zugreifen, die die Schulen oder die Schulträger vorher noch äh bestimmen sollen.
Und du fragst dich ernsthaft, was, was das für eine Katastrophe sein soll.
Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie so ein Handy hast, wo wo eine ausgewählte Anzahl an Bildungsinhalten zugänglich ist, ne? Dann frage ich mich ja schon mal, wie wird denn diese.
Auswahl getroffen. Ist YouTube dann vollständig gesperrt? Oder nur bestimmte Kanäle?
Geht's ja schon mal los. Kann ich irgendwie äh ne, kann ich Daily Show nicht gucken, aber MyLab oder was, ja? Äh fände ich äh fänd ich schon mal enorm. Also du.
Das ist technisch.
Überhaupt nicht sinnvoll umzusetzen und meine größte, mein größtes Problem damit ist, ich habe dann mal so an meine Bildungshistorie gedacht, ja? Und habe mir überlegt, wo habe ich eigentlich.
Die tatsächlich für meine Bildung.
Also als als Bürgerin oder Bürger dieses Landes relevanten Informationen bezogen und.
Für meine Information, die vielleicht für mich nachher im Verlaufe meines Studiums oder meiner beruflichen,
meines beruflichen Werdegangs relevant waren. Die kamen ganz sicherlich nicht von irgendeiner einmal im Jahr aktualisierten Liste der.
Der bundesdeutschen Bildungsinhalte, ja? Also das ist wirklich.
Es ist so eine Katastrophe und da müssen wir gar nicht erst anfangen mit dem Thema ähm.
Mit dem Thema äh Netzneutralität und so weiter, ne? Weil was was stell dir vor, was das für die Schule bedeutet. Wenn du das Kind bist mit dem, mit dem Handy, was wurde bei jedem Link, wo du draufguckst, ähm irgendwie,
sein muss, dass er gleich wieder steht. Äh Entschuldigung, hier endet äh das das,
Hier, hier endet das Bildungsgebiet Deutschland. So, das kann doch irgendwie nicht das doch nicht denkbar, oder?
Ich meine, es ist vollkommener Quatsch und ich meine grad das Beispiel, äh mit einzelnen Channels sperren kriegst du halt gar nicht hin bei YouTube. Also ich meine, dieses diesen Grad an Sperrungen
also entweder YouTube oder kein YouTube so und dann,
mit gefangen und jetzt irgendwie YouTube aus dem Bildungsprogramm rauszunehmen. Ich meine, da kann man's auch einfach mal gleich vergessen. Das ist halt auch immer so ein bisschen diese Angst, ne, die da ist, so dieses.
Das Internet könnte irgendwie böse sein, das Internet könnte dich ablenken das ja
Die nehmen ja dann das andere, als es eigentlich gedacht war. Ist auch so ein bisschen diese Diskussion mit wir können ja unter äh wir können ja Bedürftigen äh Familien jetzt irgendwie kein Geld geben, das versaufen die ja dann nur,
weißt du? Und und so unterstellt man quasi auch Schülern, dass sie nicht lernen wollen. Und nichts könnte ja wirklich,
Weiter weg von der Wahrheit sein, als das, also ich meine, selbstverständlich willst du lernen, sicherlich, es gibt,
einzelne, die haben Lernschwierigkeiten und so weiter, aber äh es bestätigt sich ja eigentlich immer wieder. Man muss halt nur den richtigen Rahmenbedingungen schaffen, um ein eigenständiges Lernen zu ermöglichen. Und da ist natürlich die Digitalisierung
vor allem erstmal eine Chance und nicht
erstmal ein Problem. Denn das andere Modell scheitert nicht erst seit dem Corona äh die Durchführung dieses Modells weiter erschwert, sondern das ist eigentlich ohnehin bekloppt, weil das eben
nicht diesen natürlichen Trieb zum Lernen befördert, sondern mit dieser ganzen frontalen Nummer.
Eigentlich jeden, jeden Lernwillen oft auch äh erstickt. Ähm will das nicht zu sehr generalisieren, aber.
Das scheint mir eben auch erforderlich zu sein, dass wenn man diese ganze Digitalisierung jetzt richtig angehen möchte im Weiteren, dass man ähm auch bereit sein muss,
Die alten Lernkonzepte ein bisschen zu verlassen.
Man sieht das ja auch und mein Internet ist ja hier nur ein Teil davon. Ja, also die Möglichkeit so zu greifen, ähm.
Bei den äh Schulen.
Meiner Kinder war das jetzt auch so, dass so Zettel rumging mit wir wollen erstmal erfragen, welche Eltern überhaupt in der Lage wären, jetzt einen digitalen Unterricht durchzuziehen, so habt ihr genug Geräte,
ja, stünde ein Gerät für die Kinder zur Verfügung et cetera, gibt's Internet und so. Ähm weiß ich noch nicht ganz genau, was da rauskommt,
Aber man merkt eben auch gerade bei den.
Wie du weißt nicht, ob du ein Gerät für die Kinder abgeben kannst.
Ja ich war nein.
Okay, äh du meinst.
Was das Gesamtergebnis dann letztlich ist.
Weiß ich noch nicht. Weiß ich noch nicht, ob ich also ob ich hier.
Alles meins. Na ja.
Das iPad brauche ich.
Ja ähm was wollte ich sagen? Die genau.
Schule erfasst das, ja? Das ist ja schon mal gar nicht so verkehr.
Ja, das ist schon mal ein guter erster Schritt, aber wenn du halt mit den Lehrern äh äh redest, dann stellst du halt einfach oft fest, dass da einfach extreme Ängste äh äh sind, die
teilweise ein bisschen irrational sind, so nach dem Motto, da muss ich jetzt auf einmal mit was umgehen, mit dem ich die letzten Jahre nicht gearbeitet habe so auf den letzten Metern bis zur Rente,
lasst sicherlich nachvollziehbar, aber wahrscheinlich eben auch immer wieder gestützt ähm von dem Wissen, dass man eben auch bei anderen komplexen Dingen eigentlich mit mit viel Rückhalt nicht rechnen kann
da eben die Mittel nicht viel, weil die Mittel fehlen, weil Personal äh fehlt. Es fehlt ja ohnehin schon in den Schulen sehr viel Personal. Eine Schule, die
auch nur zu hundert Prozent ihre ähm.
Ihren Unterricht bestücken kann mit Lehrern, ist ja schon gut ausgestattet und das also hundert Prozent heißt, ähm du hast für jeden Regelunterricht auch einen regulären Lehrer, eine reguläre Lehrerin am Start,
wobei hundert Prozent halt sagt, wird jemand krank, bist nicht mehr bei hundert Prozent und dann fällt der Unterricht halt aus, ne. Und äh,
da wird's halt jetzt durch diesen ganzen digitalen Ansatz, der so ein bisschen Harok ist natürlich auch nicht besser. Was auch äh ein Problem ist, was,
auch besprochen wurde, auf so Elternabenden und so,
ist das ähm man natürlich jetzt an der Stelle auch die Eltern mal ein bisschen mit einbeziehen muss, ne? Weil man natürlich gerade, was dieses ganze Corona-Haus und so weiter betrifft, wäre es ja sozusagen auch eine Chance, äh äh hier auch unterstützend,
einzugreifen. Ähm wenn man eben Systeme hätte.
Wo man zumindest mal weiß, was irgendwie überhaupt behandelt wird, was die Inhalte sind, was an Hausaufgaben gemacht werden muss und all solche Sachen, ne.
Soweit wird's einfach noch nicht gedacht. Wir müssen es noch weiter denken als bisher gedacht wird.
Das äh wäre schön, wenn das irgendwann nochmal stattfinden würde, ne.
In der Bildung. Also Bildung ist, denke ich, nach wie vor das, also dass bei allem ist auch jetzt schwierig zu sagen, bei allem, über das ich mir Sorgen mache, aber.
Um mal bei dieser bei diesen Top drei Möglichkeiten zu bleiben, die ihr die EU-Kommission hat erarbeiten lassen so. Bildung ist auf jeden Fall in meinen Top drei der der Problem dieses Landes. Ähm,
Wir kommen, müssen wir ein bisschen kürzer machen, also es geht jetzt weiter in dem Verfahren um Wiki Leaks. Das äh ich würde das mal ähm.
Verlinken. Es gibt äh eine neue Reportage und Dokumentation über äh das.
Die Maßnahmen, die Julian Assange sich in der equatorianischen Botschaft,
über sich ergehen lassen musste. Es ist außerdem nun öffentlich geworden, dass er,
eine Lebenspartnerin hat, mit der er zwei Kinder hat, äh die ähm da eben auch unter ganz enormer Überwachung versucht wurden, geheim zu halten, ja, vor dieser,
diesem Unternehmen UC Global, was da wohl offensichtlich für,
Zitat aus einer E-Mail des Geschäftsführers unserer amerikanischen Freunde ähm den Jury den überwacht hat. Ähm.
Die haben unter anderem irgendwelche Pläne gehabt,
einem dieser Kinder den Schnuller zu klauen, um dann einen Vaterschaftstest machen zu können, um prüfen zu können, ob das die Kinder von Julian Assange sind und diese,
äh die Mutter und der Vater Julian Assange haben quasi in der Zeit in dieser Botschaft diese Kinder,
nie. Also er hat die quasi immer versteckt. Ja und da sind andere Leute mit den Kindern reingekommen, damit weil der sich in der Botschaft, in der sich da aufgehalten hat, beobachtet gefühlt hat und tatsächlich, er wurde beobachtet, da hat er sich alles nicht eingebildet,
war so, dass die da halt, dass er quasi heimlich in irgendeiner Kammer dann mal seinen seinen Sohn halten konnte, so, ne.
Während die da draußen saßen und dachten, na der ist aber ganz schön langer mit dem Kind,
in dem Kabuff, wahrscheinlich ist das Seinke, wir müssen dem Kit den Schnuller klauen und einen Vaterschaftstest machen, also völlig, völlig Perverse, Irre, die dir da irgendwie.
Bewacht haben, ja? Und jetzt äh geht's aber natürlich in dem aktuellen äh Verfahren in Großbritannien um.
Auslieferung an die USA ist, ich denke, es ist sehr, sehr, sehr klar und sehr offensichtlich, dass äh man,
wenn man, wenn Julian Assange in die USA ähm ausgeliefert wird, dass das.
Garantiert katastrophale Konsequenzen für ihn hat, weil er eine politisch verfolgter ist. Und was sie versuchen, ihm da anzudichten mit er wäre ähm.
Er hätte irgendjemanden zum Hacking angestiftet oder so, da habe ich mitunter jetzt in den Anklageschriften Sachen gelesen, ja, dem wird äh,
Zum Beispiel ernsthaft vorgeworfen, auf dem CCC-Kongress vorgetragen zu haben. Ja, ähm weil die Anklage ihn damit in die Nähe von Hackern.
Bringen möchte und damit ihm quasi diese,
diese äh journalistische Rolle der Veröffentlichung von brisanten Materialien, die ganz ohne Zweifel im Interesse der Öffentlichkeit waren, quasi wegzunehmen und ihn zu einem Anstifter
zu zu kriminellen,
zu kriminellen Handlungen zu machen, ja? Und da schrecken sie noch nicht einmal davor, zurück eben zu sagen, ja, der hat hier auf den Hackerkonferenzen auch gesprochen, ist ein Hacker, ja? Und das äh ist natürlich ähm also.
Da haben wir auch schon schon Regierungsmitglieder und äh Datenschutzbeauftragte und so, die haben da auch schon alle gesprochen. Wahrscheinlich auch alles Kriminelle. Ja. Du auch.
Natürlich, natürlich. Aber also ich denke, gut, aber ich ich sage ja auch gar nicht, dass ich kein Krimineller.
Und ich sage nicht, ich werde Journalist. Ähm so dann kommt ja ähm also da das.
Es gibt da nichts Neues zu sagen. Und das ist auch das, was, glaube ich, an diesem Verfahren genau das Schlimme ist. Eigentlich können sich alle seit wissen alle, die es grob sich mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt haben, seit Jahren,
dass es da um einen politisch Verfolgten geht, der dem in den USA sicherlich keine guten,
keine guten Erfahrungen auf ihn warten, sondern erbarmungslose Rache des,
Militärs und der Geheimdienste und der Regierung der USA.
Ähm das ist kein faires Verfahren, was ihm da ähm entgegensteht und das ist äh wirklich.
Haarsträubend, was, was ihn da droht. Und da muss man jetzt genau hinschauen und genau drauf achten und hoffen, hoffen, hoffen, dass Großbritannien nicht so wahnsinnig ist, äh den ernsthaft in die USA auszu ähm.
Auszuweisen und das äh ich fürchte tatsächlich, die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch ist, dass sie das tun werden. Tja.
Für Facebook wird's ähm eng, ja? Die haben jetzt einen blauen Brief aus Irland bekommen von der Datenschutzbehörde, weil ja quasi geurteilt wurde, dass,
Rechtsgrundlage, mit der sie die Daten europäischer Kundinnen in die USA exportieren.
Verschwunden ist. Wir erinnern uns, Privacy, Shield ist nicht ähm.
Standardvertragsklauseln ist nicht, Facebook macht aber einfach weiter, äh laufen jetzt hier in,
Boris Johnsons Mania weiter gegen die Wand. Äh da da könnte es also interessant werden, aber tja, muss man wahrscheinlich auch sagen, ganz ehrlich.
Bisher ist da ja sowas äh bisher hat äh konnte ja immer die Politik noch abwenden, dass das Geschäftsmodell von Facebook,
nennenswerten Schaden nimmt. Also jetzt muss die Politik sich echt anstrengen,
um Facebooks Machenschaften da jetzt noch irgendwie schnell wieder eine Rechtsgrundlage zu geben, nicht dass nachher die Interessen dieses Unternehmens verletzt würden. Ja, da wird's also jetzt echt eng.
So und dann haben wir noch eine letzte kurze Nachricht ähm.
Wir haben hier auch immer wieder drüber berichtet und Konstanze hat ja auch im äh Lokbuchnetz Politik öfter darüber berichten über das Verfahren gegen den,
also den äh Großbritannien Geheimdienst, den den UK Geheimdienst, ähm die Klage von Privacy International,
mit mehreren Organisationen und eben Konstanze für den CCC auch dabei. Geht um die weitreichenden.
Hacking Operationen des GCHQ und da wurde ja quasi das Verfahren in.
Großbritannien,
hatte ging erstmal an das IPT, das Investor Tripinal, was die Klage zwanzig sechzehn zurückgewiesen hat, aber die Spionageaktivitäten bestätigt hat. So, dann ähm.
Haben, die jetzt gesagt, okay, dann müssen wir jetzt, wenn wenn hier diese Klage abgewiesen wird und wir nicht in Großbritannien,
mit den nationalen Gerichten klagen können, dann müssen wir,
an den ähm EGMR, Europäischen Gerichtshof, der für Menschenrechte, ja, die haben jetzt aber entschieden, ja, diese,
Hacking Aktivitäten des sind ein besonders starker Eingriff in die Grundrechte der Betroffenen.
Es sind Schutzmaßnahmen notwendig.
Aber ähm diese Gruppe Privacy International und die Koalition, die da eben klagt, habe nicht.
Den alle nationalen Klagewege erschöpft und könnte sich deswegen noch nicht an den IGMR wenden. Ja und ähm.
Jetzt sagt die britische Regierung hat aber klar gemacht, dass man gegen die IPT-Entscheidung nicht klagen kann. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, die prüfen zu lassen,
vor einem nationalen Gericht, weil das Investor aus Tribüne eben keinem dieser anderen Gerichte untersteht. Ähm.
Der EGMR sagt aber ja, jetzt musst du aber trotzdem nochmal irgendwie vor ein nationales Gericht. Das heißt, die werden dann jetzt versuchen, vor irgendeinem anderen äh hoheitlichen Gericht äh Großbritanniens diese Klage noch einmal anzubringen und das.
Auch wieder so so bezeichnend, ja, dass du dich hier gegen, du willst dich gegen eine klare Grundrechtseinschränkung zur Wehr setzen,
Grundrechtsverletzungen,
Zur Wehr setzen die relativ eindeutig an den Verfassungsrechten kratzt, ja oder an den Menschenrechten kratzt und die Gerichte sagen dir,
Ja
Du, äh da hast du wahrscheinlich einen Punkt. Das sehen wir auch so. Das ist auf jeden Fall wichtige Frage. Allerdings fehlt dir der Passierschein A achtunddreißig, ähm damit wir uns damit auseinandersetzen könnten. Äh und deswegen äh sorry.
Das ist also das das ist genau das Problem, was wir dieser, was man dieser Massenüberwachung durch Geheimdienste.
Sagt, nachsagt, dass sie eben nicht der äh rechtsstaatlichen Kontrolle unterliegt und dass man keine Möglichkeiten hat, dagegen äh sich,
dagegen zu klagen. Ja, das ist das Problem. Und da sagen die Gerichte, jo, hast recht, das ist echt das Problem. Ähm allerdings bei uns kannst du da nicht gegen klagen.
Genau. Na ja.
Ja, das heißt, jetzt werden sie trotzdem nochmal äh in Großbritannien so proformer quasi sich nochmal ablehnen lassen von so ein paar anderen äh Gerichten, um dann nochmal den Weg zum IGMR zu gehen.
Um dann hoffentlich, aber da müssen sie wahrscheinlich vom EGMR gegen die Abweisung der Klage oder was auch immer, ey, das wird ähm.
Unterliegt denn äh Großbritannien noch dem IGMR überhaupt?
Das da hätte ich gedacht, dass du das besser weißt als ich. Ich weiß nicht, ob die ob die sich auch von den Menschenrechten verabschieden oder nur von dem nur von ihren Fisch.
Das tun sie unter Garantie. Da sind sie auf jeden Fall auf einem ganz guten Weg. Äh auf jeden Fall scheißen sie drauf. Das kann man äh schon mal sagen. Allerdings ist der IGMR.
Ähm auch kein Gerichtshof der EU, sondern des Europarats.
Also der Council of Europe, der nicht der Rat der Europäischen Union ist, was ja wiederum die dritte Säule der äh EU ähm Legislative ist, also die Versammlung aller Staatsoberhäupter
Ähm von daher äh gehören sie dem auch weiterhin an. Bis sie da auch noch austreten.
Also auch Russ, dass Russland äh sogar die Türkei ist da mit drin, also die richtig geilen Staaten alle dabei.
Okay, dann kommen wir doch jetzt mal zu den Terminen.
Genau.
Ja, so Termine gibt's äh natürlich nicht so viele, wie ihr euch schon äh äh denken könnt, aber ähm ein bisschen wird es zumindest probiert, denn jetzt wäre ja auch die Zeit gekommen für die äh Datenspuren
in diesem Jahr sich als die Spuren ähm in die Öffentlichkeit drängen. Und ähm ja, sie wollen's nicht komplett ausfallen lassen, so ähnlich wie wir das mit dem Kongress ja auch schon gehört haben und werden versuchen, etwas Neues zu machen,
Ähm aktuell gibt's wohl so an die achtzehn,
Einreichung bereits, die auf einer Stage dann online gestreamt werden sollen, wer trotzdem vorbeikommen will, kann das auch machen. Und äh und sich über dreißig geplante Präsenzroboter vor Ort einklinken und die Location erkunden,
was auch immer da, dahinter stecken mag. Genau, das Motto der Datenspuren dieses Jahr ist mehr
Utopie wagen, Fahrplans, äh Streaming-Links, alles weitere unter Datenspuren Punkt DE und das Ganze findet statt vom,
achtzehnten bis zwanzigsten September zwanzig zwanzig.
Das ist ja schon in einer Woche.
Das ist schon in einer Woche, so sieht's aus. So sieht's aus. Tja, Timeline.
Das bringt uns ans Ende der Sendung.
Dann nehmt, nehmt bitte noch bei am Heavy Sale teil.
Eure Ideen für die Remote KOS Experience und euer Input. Hm.
Und dann hätte ich noch zu danken. Letzte Woche haben wir ja nur.
Einer Person gedankt. Ähm da haben sich auch einige noch ein bisschen drüber gewundert, was denn das äh Auto äh der Bonustrack dann war. Äh dazu haben wir äh auch nochmal in den zu dieser Sendung.
Verlinkt, worum es da ging.
Und dann würde ich an dieser Stelle danken, Maren, Jan, Wolfgang Jendrik, Alexandra, Alexander, Ralf und Jani,
und äh besonders für dich noch danken Nils und Gerold. Vielen Dank für die,
persönliche Unterstützung und äh ich freue mich immer sehr darüber.
Genau.
Von mir der Dank an alle treuen äh Spenderherzen, die äh Meterebene und Logbuch Netzpolitik hier äh regelmäßig befüllen und ja, ansonsten danke fürs Zuhören, wie immer. Das war's für diese Woche.
Ciao, ciao.
Bis bald.